great thanks I changed the title but
same theme at least so this is based on
joint work with Ilyas the iconic colas
Jerry Lee
Gotham cometh in Daniel Caine so let me
tell you at the outset what this talk is
about so this talk is about having your
cake and eating it too
so getting estimators in high dimensions
that are computationally efficient and
are also provably robust so before I get
there that's what I'm working up towards
before I get the high dimensional robust
estimation let me start off with one
dimensional robust estimation and before
I do one dimensional robust estimation
let me start off with one dimensional
statistics just to make sure we're on
the same page so what you usually call
classic parameter estimation is this
broad class of questions
imagine you're given samples from some
unknown distribution but it lives in
some nice family so this will be the
example that we come back to many times
but in high dimensions so for example in
one dimension you could be given sample
from a Gaussian but you don't know its
mean mu and its variance Sigma squared
and the question is first can you
accurately estimate its parameters so
you know the answer to this is a
resounding yes
obviously in fact you could use just the
empirical mean take the average of your
points of their values that converges
very quickly to the mean mu and you
could take the empirical variance and
that converges very quickly to the true
variance so this is classic parameter
estimation and in fact it's one example
of a much broader paradigm which is
maximum likelihood estimation which is
something that was pioneered by Fisher
who developed a lot of the basic theory
in the early 1900s and the empirical
mean and empirical variance are just two
cases of this maximum likelihood
estimator so there are a lot of
wonderful properties about the maximum
likelihood estimator things like you
know when you take enough samples it
really does converge to the true
setting the parameters under tame
conditions in fact it's even optimal in
some sense because it actually has the
smallest possible variance eventually
you should take the number of samples to
infinity so a lot of times you hear this
introduction about the maximum
likelihood estimator and in theory talk
one of the starting points is you know
but how do you actually compute it and
then you ask are there computationally
efficient procedures instead so today
I'm gonna take a different jumping-off
point which is following the lines of 2q
who asked questions like all right so
the maximum line code estimator is great
and works when you really are given
samples from some true model but what
about errors in the model itself what if
you're given samples that aren't quite
from a Gaussian in fact then Tukey's
famous work that launched the field of
robust statistics he asked exactly this
question about one dimensional gaussians
what he did was he took a one
dimensional Gaussian and he added noise
to it in his case a Gaussian with larger
variance and studied empirically how
many of the existing estimators
performed now you can take this and it
becomes an entire field the family of
questions which robust statistics there
are tons of books and papers on it which
really ask questions of the flavor
well what estimators behave well in a
neighborhood around the model as opposed
to working just when you're given one
particular model so this will be the
setting that we talk about and let's
actually build up the notions from
robust statistics in the one-dimensional
case if we move on to high dimensions so
let's revisit this 1 dimensional
Gaussian learning problem from the
perspective of robust statistics and
talk about what happens when there
errors in the model itself so this will
be the question but it'll take me a
couple slides to actually formalize what
I mean by the noise and what I mean by
learn the parameters in the presence of
noise but roughly the goal is the
obvious one is you know instead of
actually getting samples from this
idealized model we're getting samples
from this actual model which isn't quite
Gaussian but it's close and we can think
of the noise as being the difference in
their PDFs and we want to be able to
recover the parameters in spite of the
fact that the samples aren't really from
a Gaussian
you're not couldn't following the
Gosling with that noise yes I'm not
convenient is for simplicity so how are
we actually going to constrain this
noise there are a lot of ways that make
sense let me tell you a very natural way
so one way and they're actually two
equivalent ways of thinking about this
is if you take the difference of the two
PDFs one way you could constrain the
noise is just by constraining the l1
norm of that difference so ensuring that
whatever that difference is between the
idealized model and the true one you
know isn't too large an l1 mass now
there's another equivalent way to think
about this we think about the l1 norm
being at most o of epsilon we could
instead think about this as imagine that
the adversary that someone takes a bunch
of samples from a gaussian but then the
difference between these two pdfs is
where you're actually changing the
samples in your set so another way to
think about this is it's like the
adversaries corrupting about an epsilon
fraction of your points in fact all of
the results in the stock are going to
work with the even stronger model where
you imagine an adversary takes a bunch
of samples can look at them and then
decide which epsilon fraction of them to
corrupt completely arbitrarily so this
is our model for noise is that our
adversary has absolute control over
about an epsilon fraction of the points
this actually generalizes many of the
standard models and robust statistics
one of the most famous examples is
Huber's contamination model which
corresponds the constraint that an
adversary is only allowed to add samples
to your set instead of actually
subtracting them in some places so in
any case this will be how we constrain
the noise and just introduce a little
bit of nomenclature I'm going to call
the outliers the points that the
adversary has touched and has moved in
arbitrary ways and the things that
actually the adversary didn't touch I'm
going to refer to as in liars so this is
how we constrain the noise and the only
other thing left for me to formalize
this question is to try and set the goal
so if this is our model for noise well
how do we want to measure the closeness
of the parameters that were striving to
learn so in what norm do we want to make
sure that the parameters are close to
the true
parameters that were given noisy access
to in this case there's a very natural
norm to do it is the total variation
distance which is just half of the l1
distance between the two PDFs why is
this the natural thing is because the
way that we've set up the adversary he's
arbitrarily corrupting an epsilon
fraction the samples
well that guarantees that whatever our
observed distribution is the total
variation distance the idealized
distribution is bounded by Epsilon the
the difference between these two is
exactly the thing that we constrained
the l1 norm of so in this problem we're
given samples that come from a
distribution that's epsilon close and
total variation distance to a Gaussian
so the natural goal then is to find
another Gaussian that's close and total
variation so if you're given samples
from something that's close on TV find
something else that's also close on TV
so you can State this called two
different ways you could be looking for
an estimate which is a Gaussian whose
total variation to the ideal one is o of
Epsilon or you can think about it as
actually finding the best approximation
among your family of hypotheses to
whatever your given samples from so this
is the type of question we'll be
interested in given samples that are
epsilon close in TV find something else
that's about epsilon close in TV it's a
very natural question and first I should
tell you a little bit about what's known
in robust statistics so first I ask the
question non robustly there was an
obvious choice for how to do it was the
empirical mean and the empirical
variance and the first question we
should ask is in this type of model
where an adversary is allowed control do
the empirical mean an empirical variance
still work and in this case the answer
is a resounding no in fact many of you
probably know the reason for this is
because if the adversary has control
over some small fraction of samples what
he can do is he can put a tiny little
bump in the distribution now that bump
he can push arbitrarily far out and the
result is that the mean of this
distribution is diverging to infinity as
he pushes that bump further and further
out in fact the variance is diverging to
infinity too so what this means is the
statement that a single corrupted sample
can arbitrarily corrupt the estimates of
the empirical mean empirical covariance
so what should you actually do to
estimate the mean and variance in these
types of robust statistics models well I
think many of you might be able to guess
what you can do with the mean so does
anyone have a guess what you should do
the median right now what about the
variance any guesses well if the median
works how about doing a median of
medians that's called the median
absolute deviation and this pair
actually does work so let me tell you a
folklore fact about this pair of
estimates that if you use the right
scaling content for this median absolute
deviation you take the median then this
has about as good as statistical
guarantees you can hope for you're given
samples that are epsilon close and total
variation to a Gaussian and what it
learns with the median and the median
absolute deviation is something that's
epsilon close in TV that's great so it
completely solves this one-dimensional
statistical problem and you could also
call this properly agnostically learning
a 1d Gaussian that's another way but now
I can get to what's the main point of
this talk with this yeah yeah these are
with the way I stated adherence with
constant probability but there's some
log one every Delta dependence on these
things but I'm going to suppress all of
the with high probability types of
statements but good question now I can
get through what's the main question
that I'm gonna be interested in with
this as the back story about robust
statistics and what's true in one
dimension the natural question is what
can you do in high dimensions and you
know in fact we have all sorts of high
dimensional data that are not just not
living in one dimension but are truly
high dimensional so you know one of the
examples keep in the back of your mind
are things like microarrays which really
you're working with about 10,000
different genes so your data points
might actually live in some huge
dimensional space so what's actually
known about high dimensional robust
estimation even for this problem
so the question I'll be interested in
this will be the main problem for the
stock is the natural generalization to
high dimensions
given it's such a basic question it's
surprising that you know the bounds were
so wide open what was true here but
here's the question given samples from a
high dimensional Gaussian where with
something close to a high dimensional
Gaussian can you learn anything else
that's close and TV so something that's
roughly epsilon in TV and there gonna be
two special cases that I'm going to pay
special attention to once we solve these
two special cases we'll actually go to
solve the entire thing so one special
case is when I promise you the
covariance is the identity in that case
all you're trying to do is find this
high dimensional mean that I'll call the
unknown mean case and another case which
I'll promise you that the mean is zero
and all I want to do is find this high
dimensional covariance these subproblems
are like trying to figure out what is
the high dimensional analog of the
medium and the high dimensional analog
of the median absolute deviation that's
what we'll need to do to solve these two
problems so let me tell you what's known
in fact even in just the special case of
the unknown mean it's kind of
interesting if you go through all of the
existing approaches so one of the
standard approaches within robust
statistics is what's called the two key
medium so it's not so important what
this is for this talk it's some notion
of the deepest point among a cloud of
points in high dimensions but it's a
difficult thing to search for now it has
a fantastic error guarantee so if you
could compute the two key median if you
were given samples that were epsilon
close to a gaussian you would learn the
mean within distance Epsilon that's
terrific but the problem is that it's
well known to be np-hard to compute it
so you're stuck with estimators that
really only make sense some very low
dimensional problems for this type of
approach now maybe that's just the wrong
way to generalize the median to high
dimensions another way that you can try
generalizing the median to high
dimensions is the geometric meeting that
looks for the point that minimizes the
sum of the occlusion distances instead
of the sum of squares of Euclidean
distances that's not only poly-time
computable you can even compute it and
approximate it in nearly linear time but
the trouble is that it achieves a really
awful error guarantee so how close is it
as a function of the dimension well
you've got the X
salon but you also have a root D sitting
here so it loses a polynomial factor in
the error guarantee that depends on the
dimension and I'll go into more details
about why this is really really bad in
the next slide but first let me finish
my discussion of this previous
literature there are other things you
can do like tournament estimators where
what you do is you look over large sub
samples of the data set each one of them
gives you an estimate for the mean and
you would run some sort of tournament
between these hypotheses that gets error
of Epsilon but it runs in time n to the
O of D so again infeasible in high
dimensions you can do something else
that's called pruning which is just when
you're given points in high dimensions
maybe you throw away all the points that
are just stupidly far away from the
other ones that actually you can do
really quickly but again falls into this
trap of having error of epsilon times
root D so there are tons more but I'm
running out of space on the slide yep
that's right so for all of this and
we're talking about n being polynomial
in D yeah so I will when I get to the
main theorem results but I should warn
you as a caveat that my goal here is
just the C what's true in high
dimensions with polynomial sample
complexity and trying to understand
whether you can do this with nearly
optimal sampler complex' have no idea
and that's a great open question yep
so this isn't TV because total variation
is a great way to measure it because
you're given samples that are close in
TV so you want to find something else
that's close on TV the other way to
think about it is if you choose the
wrong norm to measure your parameter
distance it's very easy to hide
polynomial into the dimension factors
and this way you have to be honest about
whether or not there are such factors in
any case we could call this you know
because we're theorists some type of
price problem right maybe it is just the
price of robustness that all of these
known estimators are either hard to
computer they lose polynomial factors in
their dimension and what I want to do
first is I want to emphasize why this is
really awful that they lose these
factors one way to think about it is
that you know total variation distance
is always at most one so in fact how
small does the error need to be to have
any non-trivial error guarantee you need
the fraction of errors to be at most one
over root deep that's what's so bad
about it or to put it concretely for
these micro arrays you're talking about
even without worrying about what the
hidden constants are you can only
tolerate 1% of errors at most even
though in principle robust statistics
tells you you can tolerate much higher
fractions we just don't know how to
compute those estimators so this is my
goal list understand what should be true
for high dimensional robust statistics
can you have your cake and eat it too
all right so is robust estimation
algorithmically even possible in high
dimensions it's not so clear from this
discussion yep
or can you get excellent plus something
which depends on the number of samples
that you you know for those estimators
yeah it's always you mean what do those
this is actually not a sample complexity
issue that those estimators when they
get epsilon times root D they would
still get that even if you took a much
larger polynomial number of samples
because your adversary just has control
over the same fraction of samples it did
and it doesn't actually help you know
it's still I mean so the question is
what are the information theoretic
limits if you throw away let's let's
table that question because see the
point is that
so when huber studied this he studied in
a minimax setting but in fact every time
you change the model and you make it
stronger the adversary can see the
samples and then change them then then
actually strictly changes the constant
so a bunch of these things you know it's
not so clear what the optimal constants
would be and there are cases where i can
say more later but you know right now we
only have exelon times root d i haven't
asserted anything yet so let me assert
something stronger so here's our main
result is that actually you can do
robust estimation in high dimensions
without losing dimension dependent
factors so in fact so the sample
complexity r is polynomial but it's
suboptimal in that way it's a very
interesting question to try and get
something with d over epsilon squared
but let's table that issue given samples
that are epsilon close and total
variation distance to a high dimensional
Gaussian you don't know either the mean
or the covariance so the full problem
then you can actually impala time
compute estimates mew hat and sigma hat
which how close are they there's no D's
in that it's epsilon times Polly log 1
over epsilon so in fact you get
non-trivial guarantees even for epsilon
which are constants independent of the
dimension and that's the main result in
fact there's another way to think about
this which I like can fits into the
theme of this workshop is actually not
only do things like the two key median
work for robust statistics if you could
compute them but they're basically the
only things at work so when you actually
learn some you had in some sigma hat
that really is close what you're really
doing is you're approximating the Tukey
median and some of the high dimensional
robust variances in an interesting semi
random model where many of the samples
did come from a gaussian so a lot of
these worst-case hardness guarantees
actually do go out the window when you
have the right model things like Huber's
contamination law so that's I think one
of the other cool punch lines now
actually our paper had so many authors
because it was the merge of two
different papers around the same time
there was yet another paper so there are
some results of lie around Venn Paulo
which study the same problem now
comparing parameter distance the total
variation is a little tricky but the way
to parse this is that roughly what this
translates do is that you learn the
Gaussian within epsilon to the one-half
times log to the one-half D in total
variation and the nice thing about their
result and our result in many of the
other things is that they do work for
non Gaussian distributions too and once
you know how to do these types of things
how to get high dimensional robust
estimation there's a lot of problems
that suddenly become within reach so in
fact there's a general recipe that I'm
going to give you for how to do robust
high dimensional estimation and across
both papers they get applications to
different things so we got some
applications the product distributions
mixtures of spherical gaussians they got
applications the singular value
decomposition of the presence of noise
and independent component analysis but I
won't really have time to touch on those
more yep
I can see the samples and then decide
which fraction to arbitrarily yeah yeah
that's right because I'm gonna focus on
the simpler model but it does work for
that model but this seems like a more
compact way to say this yeah that's
right that's right
all right so let me at least yep non
spherical symmetric yeah
no no the mixtures of product the
product distributions are non Gaussian
and or non spherically symmetric but
those results actually do rely on being
somewhat close the spherical that's a
good question all right so now that I
told you at least the background of
robust statistics what was known before
and what's known now what I want to do
in the remainder of the talk is I want
to tell you that there's actually this
general recipe for how to design robust
estimators and high dimensions so all
I'm gonna do and the rest of the talk is
I'm gonna explain what the different
steps in this recipe look like in fact
step two will be the key one but let me
start from the beginning so let's focus
on just the unknown mean case where I'm
trying to learn this mean you and I'm
promised the covariance is the identity
and let's try and understand what this
recipe looks like and I'll go through it
slowly so the first step in this recipe
is you know total variation distance is
a bit tricky to work with it's a very
natural notion of you know the norm
because of the model we're working in
but the first goal is to find a good
parameter distance that works roughly is
good for controlling the total variation
so what distance on our parameters will
be good enough to guarantee that we
actually are close and total variation
distance here's the basic fact I'm gonna
use is that if you take two gaussians
where the mean it were that where the
covariance is the identity and they have
different means their total variation
distance is bounded by the Euclidean
distance between them in fact that's
roughly tight that if the Euclidean
distance is epsilon then their total
variation distance really will be about
epsilon in this case this is really
simple to prove but I'm not going to
prove it the way that you prove these
things use Pinsker inequality which
relay
the square of the total variation to the
KL divergence and the point is that
they're well known formulas for the KL
divergence between two gaussians so when
you plug in that formula and use it
using Pinsker to bound the total
variation this is what you get out in
the special case of the unknown meet so
this is the right metric to control
total variation distance in this first
case and it tells us that our goal is to
be close in Euclidean distance in high
dimensions to the unknown mean we want
to get Otilia of epsilon close that's
our new goal so this is step one all
right so now let me tell you what's the
key step in this for the unknown mean
case it's pretty simple is really step
two which is let's try and use the naive
estimators the empirical mean to begin
with now you know many works that study
robustness in high dimensions what they
do is they try and find all outliers
that's not what we're gonna do instead
what we want to do is we just want to
detect when our naive estimator has been
compromised when the adversary in the
points they've you know gotten the
ability to control has really moved the
estimate away from the truth so what
would this look like you know imagine I
give you a sample of points which in
high dimensions they're roughly at the
same distance away now if the adversary
has moved the empirical mean far away
from the true mean he could have done
that by collecting a bunch of points in
some low dimensional space and how far
would they be out they be route D out
and their epsilon fraction of them so
that's exactly where this epsilon times
root D comes from is that's how he would
move the mean very far away this would
be one way that the adversary could
actually really badly corrupt you is he
could hide in some direction in high
dimensional space and put a bunch of
points that are route D away from the
true mean but then he actually moves
your empirical mean along that direction
by epsilon times root D so this would be
like one of the canonical ways that you
would try and corrupt your estimates of
course he could do it not just in a line
but in a subspace and so on question
that's right exactly exactly exactly
because that's exactly the point does
that if I didn't show you what the
colors were here then you wouldn't be
able to detect which ones were outliers
or not but you would know that there are
many of them in some directions so a lot
of them are outliers and if there were
further away from that ball then you
really would know that they're outliers
so this is the most interesting case
they're trying to figure out how the
adversary can go about compromising the
naive estimator
but now the intuition is very simple is
that when the adversary has done this
the point is that there is a direction
in which the variance is too large the
variance should have been won in that
direction if he hadn't corrupted any of
the points but when he really has moved
her estimate very far away from the
truth he's created a direction which the
variance is large that tells us where
many of the outliers live and it tells
us how to purify our sample so you can
make that precise this is the key lemma
I'm not going to prove it but this is
the lemma that underlies the unknown
mean case is that it turns out that if
you take enough samples and you compute
the empirical mean and empirical
covariance then if the empirical mean is
far away from the true mean how far at
least epsilon times root log 1 over
epsilon then that means that there
actually has to be a direction where the
variance is noticeably off from one it
needs to be one plus this quantity so
this is actually a meta statement you
know the important takeaway is that in
order for an adversary to mess up the
first moment the mean the empirical mean
there has to be an echo of what he's
done in the higher order moments and
thus in the second moment and you can
detect that in that way so if we have
this key dilemma how would we go about
designing an algorithm so in our paper
we give two different algorithms for
doing this the convex programming is
polynomial but has better sample
complexity filtering is faster and
slightly worse your sample complexity
but let me tell you the filtering
approach so how could we use this key
lemma to actually design an estimator in
high dimensions the idea is to do a
win/win analysis either you're gonna
find good parameters already or you're
gonna remove many outliers so if you for
example detect that your empirical
covariance is
very far off from the identity of the
spectral norm is at least this C prime
times epsilon log one over epsilon which
is the consequence of this key lemma you
know if the mean were far away then what
that means is that when you look at the
direction of large variance let's call
that V and you project on this direction
the variances larger than 1 it's 1 plus
Epsilon and in that direction the only
reason that there could be such a large
variance is if the outliers
disproportionately contribute to it so
it turns out that what you can do is you
can find a threshold T so that when you
just throw it all the points above that
threshold you're guaranteed that you
throw it more of the outliers than the
in lines there are some in Liars above
it but you're making progress towards
purifying the sample so what this means
is that this immediately gives us the
algorithm is that what we do is we just
hope the empirical mean works we we try
out the empirical mean but then we use
the spectral test to see if it's a
certifiably good estimate or not if this
empirical covariance has too large you
know top eigenvector then what that
means as we can use it as a direction to
prune out many of the outliers and
eventually if we continue in this way
we'd eventually run out of outliers and
we'd be left with an arbitrary subset of
the inliers
and we show us through spectral through
concentration bounds we show that
actually any such that you're left over
with would be a good estimate for the
true parameters yep that's right so what
you actually need to show is that for
every 1 minus epsilon fraction of the
subset of n liars that that actually
would be a good estimate for the mean
that's what makes some of the
concentration balance so painful is that
you don't actually have control over
which subset of the inliers you're left
with all you're guaranteed is that you
know at the end you know you have
whatever you have either you've found
certifiably good parameters that work
via the key lemma or at the end what you
have is an arbitrary subset and that
empirical mean will be good enough
that's right that's exactly what causes
the root log 1 over Epsilon but it also
makes on the concentration bounds more
painful because these are statistics
that don't concentrate arbitrarily well
as you take more and more samples
because you're quantifying over all 1
minus epsilon size subsets that's right
oh I'll talk about that more later
all right so eventually finds
certifiably good parameters and it's a
kind of long paper but let me just
summarize the main result so the running
time we get is polynomial so if n is the
sample complexity then we get n times d
squared running time and the sample
complexity is d squared over epsilon
squared
involves some interesting tricks that
actually prove that this works because
of the dependencies between the
iterations and I'm not going to talk
about the filtering approach but instead
let me the simple complexity is you know
1 over epsilon squared foriegn which is
optimal all right so let me give you a
brief glimpse of what the unknown
covariance looks like that's the more
technically involved one but the key
point is that it actually follows the
same basic recipe so if you remember all
you have are these steps first you find
a parameter distance then you figure out
when the empirical estimate has been
compromised and then you build it into
an algorithm so how do we do this in the
unknown covariance case where the mean
is 0 and the covariance is unknown once
again what you do is you find some
distance between the covariances that's
good enough to bound the total variation
this once again you use PIN screws in
equality and this is roughly type that
when this norm is large you really do
have large total variation distance and
it changes what our goal is our goal is
to find an estimate that's close
according to this metric so we want to
be Oh tilted Epsilon close distance
seems a bit strange but trust me it is
the right one and let me get to the key
points so which is you know step two is
always where the action is happening is
how do we actually detect when the
empirical covariance has been badly
compromised so in the case of the
empirical mean we saw this echo in the
second moment the same way when the
empirical covariance has been
compromised there's an echo in the
fourth moment but things get a bit more
interesting here
so imagine you get samples from n of
zero sigma without corruptions you know
what can we say about this
you know empirical estimate Sigma hat
well one of the key facts it turns out
is that if you take samples from this
Gaussian zero and Sigma for the
covariance and you create this d squared
by d squared matrix what it really is is
the flattening of a fourth order tensor
so this is a length d squared vector
because you're tense ring X with itself
you take its times its own transpose
well that actually has a very nice form
where it looks like 2 times Sigma tensor
with itself plus something else which is
really you take the D by D matrix Sigma
and you flatten it that's why I use this
flat notation and do a length D squared
vector and take its transpose with
itself now this might not look so
intuitive but let me tell you a little
something about where this comes up is
that everyone knows that for example the
fourth moment of a unit of a one
dimensional Gaussian is 3 there's a
really pedantic way to say that which is
it turns out it's 3 because the number
of perfect matchings in a size for a
graph is 3 now there's a generalization
of that fact which is called icer
lewis's theorem sometimes also called
wicks formula that allows you to compute
moments of gaussians based on sums over
perfect matches and this is what allows
you to get a nice form for what this
flattening of the fourth order tensor
looks like but the important thing is
you really have three terms here you
have two which correspond to the
matchings that respect the way you
flattened it and one of the ones that
doesn't and that's the sort of tricky
beast because this spectrally is much
larger than the other term so this makes
things very complicated because if you
hope that by corrupting your estimates
your adversary really changes the
spectral properties of em the problem is
you have this other huge thing sitting
in there that actually Dwarfs whatever
else is going on
so it turns out that there's a way to
project this out and essentially instead
of taking top eigenvectors to look at
restricted eigenvalue computations on em
which what it does is you know what the
overall algorithm looks like is you take
a guess Sigma hat you transform it by
Sigma hat to the minus 1/2
and now if these y sub I is really war
coming without noise they would be from
n of 0i and we know exactly what they're
you know flattened tensor would look
like and we would know that this
corresponding thing would have small
restricted eigenvalues and remove that
flattening piece and this gives us a
spectral test on this d squared by d
squared matrix which is really a way of
doing the same thing saying that if the
second moments were messed up there
would be an echo in the fourth moments
that allow us to actually detect many
outliers the adversary is added so I'll
very quickly say that it turns out these
two cases give you the overall algorithm
so what you do is when you're given
samples from epsilon close to a Gaussian
with unknown mean and unknown covariance
well what do you do you use the standard
doubling trick so you just take two
independent samples from it and that is
close and total variation distance to
being from a gaussian of 0 and 2 sigma
covariance and now what you can do is
you can use the algorithm for the
unknown covariance case to learn sigma
and now when you actually take whatever
your estimate is and transform the data
you're now back in the unknown mean case
where you're trying to learn the mean
knowing that the covariance is the
identity and that you're getting samples
close to that this turns out to be the
right distance you really want to look
at Euclidean distance after applying
sigma hat to the minus 1/2 in any case
this gives the overall algorithm just by
combining these two special cases so
what I want to do just in the last 2 3
minutes is mention something that you
know I'm excited about first once you
have this general recipe you can push it
to lots of other things so there are
lots of other problems that you can give
provably robust estimators and high
dimensions that avoid polynomial indeed
dependence for their error guarantees
can do things like binary product
distributions you're getting worse
dependence on epsilon but there is no D
here you get things for mixtures of
balanced product distributions that 1/6
is definitely not optimal but it's
independent of D and you also get things
for mixtures of case fee Racal gaussians
that don't have any DS but do have
kate's now the thing I'm really excited
about is actually trying these things
out so the funny thing is once you go
back to robust statistics litter
and you look at what's empirically known
actually not much as known in you know
even anything moderate dimension so I
couldn't find anything that studied
robust statistics in dimension larger
than six so a lot of these estimators
that they're proposing they work very
well in low dimensions but as soon as
you go to high dimensions then all of a
sudden they get really bad error
dependence so we tried out some
synthetic experiments from noisy samples
from a Gaussian comparing it to at least
two estimators that we can implement and
don't run in exponential time ransac in
the geometric median you can see here
that as we vary the dimension they
really do behave very badly as a
function of the dimension the error
guarantees they get in fact what's even
worse is that even for dimension 50
they're giving almost vacuous error
guarantees and how close to actually get
and this little line down here is are
out in terms of its error guarantee so
all of a sudden you can actually do
these types of things in high dimensions
without paying this huge price of
dimensionality and I wonder what else
you can do so the thing I'm really
excited about is to try and understand
where else you can apply this now that
at least some part of robust statistics
as you know practically within reach all
right so what I hope you got out of the
talk was what I gave you was an
algorithm for agnostically learning a
high dimensional Gaussian so instead of
error guarantees of epsilon times root D
what it got was epsilon times poly log
whenever Epsilon for learning the mean
and covariance in fact I give you a
general recipe for how to go about
constructing robust estimators based on
finding the right parameter distance and
then turning it into a restricted
eigenvalue problem which detects whether
or not your empirical estimator has been
compromised and I gave you some other
applications other mixture models and
maybe you know I'll close with this
question is practical robust statistics
within reach all right thank you
we said your algorithm in that craft was
at the convex programming base don't
really goes the filtering it was a
filtering so the convex programming uses
ellipsoid so it's definitely not going
to be runnable on these things it has
the advantage that theoretically we can
prove much better things in terms of its
sample complexity because we don't have
to deal with this issue about the
dependence between the different
iterations like we do in the filtering
it's more of like a soft outlier removal
but what you can do here is you can just
kind of hope it works and you know run
it with lower sampler complexity it
still does seem to work so we can punt
on this issue about whether we can
actually handle the dependency between
the iterations in a clever way and just
try it out just two months ago that
there's actually better implementations
of ellipsoid than you might have
expected that's right that's it's still
not good enough so you're talking about
like the James Stein shrinkage style
estimators yeah that's actually kind of
a different beast because you know
that's something that's not a maximum
likelihood estimator and yet outperforms
for small samples maximum likelihood but
I actually deliberately punted on that
issue because Max and likely died anyway
said is asymptotically optimal which
then the advantages of James Stein
actually go away in terms of the
correction I have no idea if you know
there could be similar Corrections that
one could do to these types of
estimators but right now you know the
question is even what's the right
practical version of this